how do i get one of the suits
you'd only hurt yourself peewee
not getting any response bobby how do
you want to play it in answer the former
martian marine climbed down from the
gunner station hand over hand in the
high gravity the muscles in her arms
were like cords of wire and her grimace
said both that the sheer effort hurt and
that she kind of liked it let them know
if they open up on us they won't get
crash couches on the way to jail she
said passing down toward the airlock i'm
just gonna slip into something more
comfortable
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna break
down the expanse season six episode two
azure dragon was a wild ride with the
promise of things starting to take shape
for a real showdown between the inners
and marco anarros drummer may have found
an ally to do her part for the belt and
abasarallo is out there pulling on some
strings i'm going to recap everything
that happened in the episode get into
all of those things plus what's going on
with philip and the crew of the rossi
right after this quick spoiler warning
if you haven't watched the second
episode of the expanse season 6 this
video won't be for you and with that out
of the way let's get into it
the episode opens on laconia again and
cara's really bad day isn't getting any
better the mother bird that she's trying
to save dies shortly after she arrives
home on the way she's almost hit by a
soldier driving what looks like a jeep
through the forest and to make it all
much worse she realizes that she
essentially poisoned the bird by giving
it part of her protein bar her mother
explains that the plants and animals
that evolved on laconia have a different
kind of chemistry that doesn't work with
ours the planet has a different tree of
life so at best our food would be
nutritionless for creatures that evolved
on laconia and at worst it would be
poison and we see that here
she's worried about the babies that were
left behind and once helped to return
them back to their nest but her mother
and father can't help because they have
to attend a meeting that the soldiers
called for all the settlers and you hear
her parents talking to each other about
the soldiers and you can take away from
that that this group of settlers has
been there for a while before the
soldiers arrived so cara and her family
aren't part of the martian breakaway
fleet they were already on the planet
when they leave to go for the meeting
cara grabs a drone that she's not
supposed to use there's a sign there
that says these aren't toys she grabs a
shovel and then she tells her little
brother zan who we met just briefly that
he can't go with her he has to stay home
after she gets the first baby back in
the nest the drone breaks and gets stuck
things still not going her way and while
she's digging the hole to bury the
mother the mysterious dog-like creature
comes over and carries the bird away
back in seoul system the rossi is docked
with a unn supply ship in the belt
they're resupplying and when they get
ready to leave they're told that their
mission specialist is transferring over
this is not something that holden was
expecting so he calls clarissa and tells
her to go to her quarters and it's funny
because he actually calls her peaches
here but it turns out to be nothing to
worry about it's just bobby and her
power armor coming aboard when he asks
what's up she says change of plans time
to lock and load a little later she'll
explain that they have located the azure
dragon it's running dark which gives it
a false sense of security and even
though it would be much easier just to
blow it up avasarala wants to capture it
so she can get her hands on all of its
data amos points out that she has a navy
for things like that holden reminds him
that she's lost strike teams before and
the optics of losing another one
wouldn't be good politically so as an
independent ship if things were to go
wrong it would be on them rather than on
her bobby makes the argument that it's
really about morale that they need a win
and that they aren't going to mess this
thing up much like the crew stuff we saw
in episode 1 this exchange establishes
where everyone is at in relation to
their role in this fight against the
free navy
no one is excited about this plan
besides bobby it makes sense for her
she's happy to get back out there and
put her skills to good use do what she
does best but that's in stark contrast
to everyone else involved amos doesn't
like the added risk and there seems to
be an ongoing thing where he's having
trouble understanding if any of this is
worth it as he said in the premiere he's
just there to kill marco before he can
kill them and you know it must be risky
if he doesn't want to do it naomi isn't
in love with the idea of bobby taking
care of the belter crew on the ship the
violence involved with that and holden
respects that even with a good plan that
this is just a difficult operation to
pull off when everyone starts to go back
to work holden asks bobby if she's heard
of any ships going missing at the ring
during transits she had heard intel
about a number of martian ships that
went dark when passing through the gates
the thinking at the time was that they
slipped off and joined inaros but the
ships had never been accounted for he
then shows her the bar keith footage and
asks for her to get him that intel on
series philip is in a holding cell and
sandrani brings marco in to see him he
undermines their authority and the laws
on series stating that this is a free
navy matter and that he'll deal with it
personally he orders that philip be
released into his custody immediately
outside he gives him back his gun and
tells him that once they get back to the
ship to clean himself up and to report
for duty johan assaulted a superior
officer and you defended yourself that's
what happened when philip looks confused
he says would you like me to punish you
some more i would think that the
embarrassment you've become since we
arrived on series would be punishment
enough back on the pella we see marco
looking at the locations of his supply
depots relative to the ring and you can
see that there are a lot of them he's
trying to figure out if there's a faster
way to get supplies to medina rosenfeld
brings up philip and how he's completely
lost his focus and the crew has
recognized this she says it probably has
a lot to do with his mother but marco
blames philip because he brought her
there in the first place he says it cost
us all so much and you get the sense
that marco resents his son because of
what happened in his quarters philip
looks through yuan's things and sees his
blood on the alligator skin vest he
watches video feeds on his hand terminal
of the two of them when they were
younger and it's clear that he does feel
remorse about what happened rosenfeld is
able to score some points by talking to
marco honestly about how the situation
is playing out he says that he wants his
son to be better and she points out that
he can't afford to be angry with so many
important things going on later philip
comes to her and says that johan's
family should be taken care of and she
reminds him of the obvious that the
official story is that he assaulted a
superior officer and if he had survived
he would no longer be in the free navy
he realizes what she's saying is true
but then she scores some points with him
by saying that they will give the family
something because this is a gracious
impulse on his part we see him struggle
with sending a message to the family and
in the end he's able to pull together
the resolve to do this as he knows he
should and you come away thinking this
is just another thing that's going to
haunt him elsewhere in the belt the
titan has rendezvoused with the in a
zombie joseph points out that they're
probably considering taking them out for
the bounty and of course they are
drummer says that walker is a smuggler
and a thief and if i had a better option
i would have used it there's an unspoken
thought between them where it's like
wait a minute is it really a good idea
then to leave michio with them and
drummer just says that she'll be safer
with them than on the tynan with her
family they meet with liang walker at
the airlock door and we learn a lot of
important things in their short exchange
the original plan was to take michio to
ganymede but he tells them that this is
going to be a problem because the free
navy took over security there and put up
checkpoints so she won't be safe this
confuses drummer she doesn't understand
why that would be a problem for him
because he's in the free navy he makes
the distinction that he's golden bow and
that some of their faction went against
marco so he's humiliating the rest of
them by giving them shitty jobs he also
says that marco doesn't like him
personally because in his own words he
intimidates him sexually and the
delivery of this and the way that
everyone sort of looks at him after is a
nice little bit of comedy he says they
aren't involved in any fighting they
only move freight when she asks what
kind things get interesting because it's
food and water and other things people
need in the belt they're transferring it
from places like ganymede and ceres to
supply depots that marco spun up all
over the belt this ties into him being
more concerned with medina and really
underlines the situation they're not
just unwilling to help series they're
actually taking stuff away from there so
you can see why sandrani's in such a
tough position even before they let his
son go after he killed somebody on the
station
hearing about those supply depots gives
drummer an idea and she invites walker
onto the tynan for that tour that he was
interested in when they start talking
they bring up marco and despite all his
faults that he is good at getting people
to follow him drummer points out that
walker doesn't seem to like it and that
she didn't either but when golden bough
splintered he did choose marco's side
and he explains that he did get caught
up in it all finally striking back
against the inners it felt glorious he
eventually asks her to get to the point
of what she's after and she lays it out
isn't he tired of getting by on a little
skim when the fat prize is right out
there for the taking they can take the
food right off inaros's plate like a
true pirate would she asks if he's still
in contact with some of the ships that
didn't join the free navy and it's clear
that she's won him over to this idea and
after this exchange you might hear book
readers referring to drummer as the
pirate queen there's a quick shot of
monica eavesdropping on unn command on
the xenobia she then goes to abasarala
to ask what's going on and she shuts her
down by telling her that she'll have her
access revoked if she keeps abusing it
we know that the buzz is over the fact
that the rossi's getting ready to do
their mission there we see them getting
suited up and there's this great moment
where amos asked bobby how he could get
one of those suits referring to her
power armor and bobby responds you'd
only hurt yourself pee wee we see
clarissa's involved she's preparing the
emp device they open both airlocks and
the azure dragon fires up their drive
indicating that they did spot them they
take off the rossi gives chase and
holden wants to put a railgun round
through their drive cone but bobby won't
let him she has operational control and
insists that they try to board the ship
she orders him to get close and hold
steady and wait for her signal everyone
that's not in power armor is pinned to
the deck the dragon is doing maneuvers
and holden does his best to stay close
and stay out of their drive plume in an
audible bobby grabs the emp and takes
this crazy leap over to the other ship
where she's able to activate that and
cut their drive amos crosses to blow the
airlock and when it's naomi's time to go
she gets a flashback to her transit to
the chet's mocha with no suit and gets
frozen in place clarissa grabs her kit
and goes instead holden joins amos
they're ready to breach while clarissa
is making sure they can't start their
reactor back up on the other side of the
ship three crew members make their way
outside naomi is able to get it together
enough to help clarissa who finds what
she needs in time but at the same time
the crew members attack her and bobby
two are coming straight on and she
starts firing at them and as that's
happening the third one sneaks up with
the clear shot of some kind of rocket
launcher and clarissa has to make a
split-second decision to activate her
mods taking the guy out and causing his
shot to miss while knocking his helmet
off and killing him at the same time
she's able to save bobby's life and when
she approaches them where they're sort
of stuck in place by their mag boots we
see that clarissa vomited inside of her
helmet you also saw that the damage the
rocket did to the ship's outer hull was
serious so it would have been a game
changer if that would have hit bobby
holden and amos get inside they shoot
the last remaining crew member they see
that they were trying to wipe the data
cores but didn't get finished in time
and as naomi is cracking the encryption
holden asked her what happened out there
and this is a really great exchange when
she says that she's all right he asked
really all right or not ready to talk
about it all right and it's the second
one and we see their connection as
crewmates as lovers as partners and he
just says okay when they get access they
realize just how many rocks the free
navy strategy involves which is
impressive and this is exactly what
abasarala needed to find out she calls
for monica after the mission is complete
she tells her that she wants to
commission her to do a project in her
words she wants the belt to see what
they're doing to us monica refuses at
first saying that she doesn't do
propaganda but then she does a really
great job of guilt-tripping her into it
she wants her to humanize earthers and
even if it won't change many minds it
might just make it a little bit harder
to feel good about killing them on the
rossi amos is with clarissa backing up
the idea that she did save bobby's life
and holden comes in and asks to talk to
her he takes responsibility for treating
her like an obligation rather than
forging a real working relationship but
tells her that they had a plan and any
changes have to go through him it has to
work that way he knows she was trying to
help but she's gotta follow the chain of
command she apologizes and acknowledges
that she made a mistake and then when he
leaves she can't help herself from
smiling because as she tells amos this
was the first time he referred to her as
part of the crew on the pela marco and
rosenfeld get word that the azure dragon
and its data were captured they know
that the inners will be able to locate
all the rocks that were on their way or
that are waiting to launch and then
they'll be able to redeploy their fleets
they're not thrilled about this but
marco assures her that when they come
for series and he believes that they
will that they'll be ready for them
apparently he has a plan but he doesn't
reveal it and the episode ends there a
really solid episode and it kind of blew
my mind when i was taking the notes
because it's short but there are so many
important details in every line of
dialogue and every interaction between
characters being able to secure the data
on all the rocks that are pointed
towards earth is as important as
abasarala made it out to be now the
conflict can move into the next phase
it's great that bobby is now on the
rossi and that the action was able to
bring them together for the time being
and even though naomi is out of sorts
because of what happened to her last
season i thought that brought out a
great moment between her and holden that
speaks volumes about the crew's
experiences together they're all sort of
at a low point here because of what's
going on but they all are loyal and
dedicated to each other there's really
nothing wrong with this episode beyond
the fact that it flew by and even though
it's impressive in its efficiency and
what it's able to get done it does still
feel short it sort of feels like fixing
a problem that didn't exist i've never
thought that the expanse would be better
if they could just trim it down some and
i think if there's one place i could say
it sort of took away from it it was
after clarissa activated her mods it was
kind of hard to track what was going on
there without going back and watching it
a couple times it doesn't lose much
considering that everything is working
so well but i was left wanting more at
the end it had some really funny moments
with bobby and walker and i thought they
did a good job of introducing him this
late in the game there are so many
little things in every episode like
holden floating down the stairs to meet
bobby and it goes without saying that
they really nailed the action sequence
drummer's scenes were great as was
abasarala and monica together and i
liked watching rosenfeld working her way
into the middle of things with marco and
phillip and i think i'll leave it there
i'll put out a follow-up video in a
couple of days and get into the x-ray
scene and whatever teasers they put out
so check back for that in the comments
let me know what you thought about the
episode what you think of the season so
far and what you're hoping to see next
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon